bonjour douglas y ait merci d'être avec
nous ce matin en direct sur arte france
joe biden rencontrait manuel macron tout
à l'heure pour la première fois lors
d'un entretien bilatéral quelles
relations futures entre la france et des
états unis
très bien joe barton était du retour de
normal donc il a commencé avec le
visitent exiger du président en grande
bretagne il a sonné le rapport spécial
entre ces deux pays et après ils
débarquent pour le continent aurore et
mme alliot marie andrée christensen
allié des états unis traditionnels
encore donc c'est une des buts
trivialité qui gênent byden été un peu
happy complet 230 bien et c'est surtout
il n'y a pas de couac aujourd'hui mais
pourtant on est quand même des sujets de
tension est ce qu'ils vont les aborder
c'est dossier divergent comme le retrait
américain de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien ou encore très récemment un
femme l affaire d'espionnage des
européens par la msa propos de laquelle
le président français a appelé je cite à
une clarté complète
oui un peu apaisé les esprits
mais ces questions par exemple
d'espionnage dns à ce sont des questions
de fond et une visite comme ça au monde
symbolique ne touchent pas des questions
de fond a dit c'est à dire le structures
de pouvoir internationale mais plutôt
ils vont valoriser et les marchands
commune donc au vide tout le monde
s'entende ennemis comme donc sais c'est
facile de s'organiser contre le colis là
on va voir les déclarations mais changer
les semis dans le système
de wes non je pense pas qu offre mais
qu'on va trop aborder ce sujet on
parlait d'un ennemi commun vous avez
abordé le coville 19 évidemment mais ce
premier déplacement du nouveau président
américain joe biden à qui choisit
l'europe avec je cite un front commun
face à la chine autre ennemi commun pour
quoi raviver la relation transatlantique
c'est parce que le leadership américain
est affaibli de plus en plus contesté
par pékin
oui dans votre mission paraît des noms
mentionnés le chantre de la partie il
dit que c'était 1941 les ennemis des
etats unis et angleterre étaient
allemands donc offre le but de
l'atlantisme c'est toujours les lits qui
libre de pouvoir mais le monde dont on
pouvoir de la chine à changer le temps
en classe terminale
on avait maintenant une amie une rivale
chinoise mais le jeu c'est toujours le
même structure géopolitiquement
l'alliance transatlantique
c'est une forte maintenir l' équilibre
de force et ce qui s'est passé depuis
quatre ans c'est un affaibli cette ces
systèmes des alliances comme autant la
prochaine étape sera à bruxelles au
tournoi représente 70% des toutes les
dépenses militaires sur la guerre
donc c'est une norme alliance il faut le
valoriser et évidemment en point d'orgue
de cette tournée européenne pour joe
biden ce sera sa rencontre mercredi
prochain avec son homologue russe
vladimir poutine à genève on entendu un
son
dans le sujet précédent de joe biden il
a dit qu'il souhaitait une relation
stable et prévisible avec la russie
vraiment oui hommes le ministre des
affaires étrangères maintenant
américaine 1 tony blinken est un ancien
soviétologue ses positions sont bien que
nous et on n'a de sens que la politique
étrangère n'est qu'un envers la russie
sera formé par ces diplomates
c'est à dire comme pendant la guerre
fois mais plutôt un valorisation des
valeurs démocratiques des menaces de
sanctions et une ligne un peu dur avec
clermont foot mais je manque de mots
durs un gain nouvelle guerre fois entre
rossi comme j'ai dit baye denis cherche
le nom marie c et ont renforcé
l'equilibre de pouvoir avec autant avec
le g7 avec les institutions en tunisien
est plutôt avec le dollar américain
il a suffisamment de force d éviter les
menace non utile mais il va parler bien
sûr des récentes hacking des systèmes
américaine dont la russie était accusé
merci douglas y est d'avoir répondu à la
question je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines